[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got huge
news about some alternate spider-man
costumes very comic book moments that
they deleted out of infinity war early
on in the process including alternate
costumes for other characters some of
which seemed like they were saving for
Avengers 4 because we have seen with
some of the Avengers new costumes are
gonna look like during Avengers 4 so we
got to break it down there's a new round
of that game giveaway it's either a Red
Dead Redemption or spider-man ps4 or
either one you guys want all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a spider-man related comment on the
video uh name a new winner at the end of
this so we're gonna start with
spider-man's black costume because
that's probably the biggest news then
I'll break down the other alternate
Avengers for costumes so you can see
early on that they planned on doing a
version of the iron spider suit that was
way more authentic to the comics then
this black version you can see is
exactly the same only black colored is
not supposed to be the symbiote but
because they were fighting for their
lives on an alien planet you can see why
early on
they would consider putting him in a
black costume to reference Secret Wars
like heaven foggy definitely didn't want
to do venom but this is the closest we
could get to symbiote without actually
doing the symbiote all of the iron
spider scenes that Tom Holland film for
infinity war were full motion capture
versions of the suit the benefit being
that the visual effects artists can make
the suit look like whatever they want
without Tom Holland having to come back
in and shoot new scenes if they want to
change the costume late in the process
but they just open up their uber version
of Photoshop that they use turn all the
colors way down and bang you have your
black costumes spider-man but based on
the early versions of these scenes the
Avengers who went to Titan to fight
Thanos would have also been fighting the
outriders in spider-man would have worn
three different costumes during the
movie the original stark tech suit that
he starts out and the iron spider suit
that he gets when they're climbing into
orbit then let just refer to this
version as the black mode iron spider
probably just a plan feature for this
version of the suit like deploying extra
armor when all the outriders were gonna
go crazy on them what ended up happening
as we all saw in the theaters that they
got rid of the outriders on Titan
because they already had way too many
characters there the fight was already
really complicated and super expensive
and because they planned these movies so
far out they probably won
to save a few of spider-man's big
costume changes for future potential
spider-man movies like far from home you
can kind of see the wheels turning in
their heads behind the scenes as they're
envisioning all this there's already too
much too soon let's save that black suit
for the next movie so we still have a
few surprises left up our sleeve the new
Steve Ditko looking black suit that
we've been seeing on the set of
spider-man far from home also looks an
awful lot like this version of the iron
spider suit this movie's a prequel
because you know in the at the end of
infinity war you turn into like a lot of
times if they have a really amazing idea
early on that hits the cutting room
floor they'll try to reuse that in a
later movie like this is really awesome
but we've already got way too much stuff
going on
we'll just include it in this future
movie it's the same deal with Joss
Whedon in the gray Hulk he originally
wanted to do grey Hulk in this big
battle with Ironman here but decided
that they were already trying to cram
too much stuff into the movie so just
told Kevin Feige here you can use grey
Hulk in a future movie if you ever want
it's just a really interesting twist for
his character this infinity war black
suit obviously wound up becoming the
Nick Fury shield stealth combat suit
we've all been seeing behind the scenes
pictures up almost like spider-man's
noir costume but with thick armor
plating and combat boots so you can see
how if they wanted to do this and it was
supposed to be this big twist like oh
wow look at this cool new black costume
spider-man is wearing it would have
completely undercut that if they had
already done it during infinity war
we've been talking about New Avengers
for costumes and yes spider-man is gonna
be in Avengers 4 but I'm not expecting
any dramatic costume changes for him
there have been rumors about multiverse
time-traveling different versions of
existing characters but most of the
spider-man moments I'm expecting are in
paying off Tony's grief because you have
to address that like Aunt May needs to
find out that Peter died then when he
does eventually come back Peter
reflecting on the totality of what he's
been through and looking forward to his
restful quote-unquote summer vacation
with his friends q far from home
giant Mysterio attack we also got a look
at the version of Thor's costumes they
almost went with during infinity war it
looks suspiciously like his new
costume that he gets during Avengers 4
but just like them holding up on
spider-man's black suit it seemed like
what happened here is that early on they
knew that they were splitting the story
up for both Avengers movies they decided
that because Thanos was going to beat
the crap out of them during infinity war
and they needed to rally during Avengers
4 the easiest way to show them growing
and becoming more badass visually is to
just give them new costumes so they just
held off on giving everyone really shiny
new costumes so thanks to some of the
toy releases we've seen what some of
those new costumes are supposed to look
like whether or not they're featured
heavily in the movie or if it's just for
a couple of quick scenes a lot of times
really cool toy stuff doesn't
necessarily translate to a lot of scenes
in a movie you also notice that they
almost decided to give him a gun is his
main weapon instead of doing the new
hammer Stormbreaker
and you can just hear all the fanboys in
the background screaming blasphemy Thor
has used guns before but because this is
such a big deal he's mostly associated
with melee weapons like axes hammers the
only part of his costume that I was
disappointed with a little bit was than
them giving him his new eye right away
instead of letting him be pirate for for
a little while longer
just wish they'd left that for Avengers
4 so he could still be pirate angel Thor
but from what we've seen Iron Man's
nanotech armor always looked like this
like there weren't that many big changes
from start to finish
the only other characters with radically
different costumes early on were Captain
America with a more military colored
armor during all the Secret Avengers
scenes during the movie I agree
completely with their final decision to
just have him wear the ripped torn
version of his Civil War armor showing
the scales underneath much better a
comic book Easter egg in a much better
visual representation for his character
arc
he's been worn down by all the tragedy
all the crap this happens in Civil War
just like the suit has been worn down
we've been talking about how do you show
characters I've grown give them costume
upgrades cue shiny comic books scale
armor and Avengers 4 and get that man
his new shield
all right Will's up at 8 minutes we just
got a load Tony don't Hulkbuster armor
prototype for caps new shield and the
making the make the I get so many
questions about Thor's magic belt them
making your it doubles his strength in
the comics so it's totally possible they
could pay that off during Avengers 4 it
would make sense if you're giving all
the characters costume upgrades and he
really wants to go toe-to-toe with a
nose let me know in the comments do you
agree with their decision to hold off on
black costumes spider-man and save that
for a future movie there is a whole
bunch of other Marvel and DC stuff
that's been dropping recently so leave
your requests for spider-man and Marvel
videos in the comments below
congratulations Joe B Romo you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here to learn about the
new Winter Soldier series that they just
announced and click here to watch Tom
Holland explained the trilogy of
spider-man movies that they're planning
at Marvel thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]